[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام للاغتيالات
السياسيه في لبنان تاريخ طويل كانت البلاد
ولا تزال مسرحا للعديد من الاغتيالات
السياسيه بسبب طبيعه الصراعات داخل
المجتمع اللبناني لاعتب
منها وجود لبنان في قلب منطقه الصراع
الرئيسيه في الشرق الاوسط نسلط الضوء
اليوم على ملف الاغتيالات السياسيه في
لبنان في ضوء التحقيق الذي اجرته قناه
الجزيره ضمن برنامج الصندوق الاسود حول
اغتيال كمال جملات رئيس الحزب التقدمي
الاشتراكي بعد اربعه عقود على وقوع
الجريمه ومع ان اصابع الاتهام كما كشف
التحقيق وتؤكدها الروايات تشير الى تورط
النظام السوري حينها في عمليه الاغت
فان الحقيقه الكامله لم تكشف
بعد كل خيوط الجريمه وشواهدها كانت تحوم
ثم تنتهي عند عنوان واحد النظام السوري
صحيح ان شخصيه بحجم الزعيم الوطني
اللبناني كمال جنبلاط كان لها عده خصوم
لكن طرفا واحدا فقط هو من اقدم قبل اربعه
عقود كامله على اطلاق الرصاص وتصفيه زعيم
الحركه الوطنيه اللبنانيه ليس الامر هنا
مجرد تكهنات عابره بل خلاصه تحقيق
استقصائي مطول انجزه فريق برنامج الصندوق
الاسود بقناه الجزيره التحقيق الذي كشف عن
تفاصيل ووثائق تخرج للعلن لاول مره عن
ملابسات اغتيال جنبلاط قدم العديد من
الشهادات والحقائق التي ترجح ضلوع النظام
السوري في مقتله فقبل اشهر قليله من تلك
الحادثه كان الجيش السوري قد دخل لبنان
باسم قوات الردع لايقاف تقدم مقاتلي
الحركه الوطنيه والفصائل الفلسطينيه نحو
معاقل الجبهه اللبنانيه التي تضم الاحزاب
المارونيه المسيحيه رفض جنبلاط التدخل
السوري ليبدا الصدام بينه وبين حافظ الاسد
ورغم تمكن الجيش السوري من بسط سيطرته على
لبنان بعد هزيمه قوات الحركه الوطنيه
وحلفائها فان ذلك لم يمنع جنبلاط من
مواصله هجومه على الاسد
[موسيقى]
الابرا
وفي ظل هذه الاجواء وتحديدا صبيحه السادس
عشر من اذار مارس عام
1977 وبينما كان جنبلاط في طريقه الى
بيروت اعترضت سياره يستقلها اربعه مسلحين
طريقه وصفوه مع اثنين من مرافقيه تحقيق
برنامج الصندوق الاسود كشف ارتباط منفذي
العمليه باحد فروع المخابرات الجويه
السوريه داخل لبنان كان يديره انذاك
الضابط ابراهيم حيجي الذي اصبح لاحقا
رئيسا لها علاوه على ان السياره التي
استعملها الجناه ثبت انها كانت بحوزه قوات
الردع قبل تنفيذ عمليه الاغتيال ولعل
اللافته في حديثه مقتل كمال جنبلاط هو
اغلاق السلطات اللبنانيه ملف اغتياله دون
توجيه الاتهام لاحد وهو السيناريو الذي
طالما تكرر وبشكل حصري ضد شخصيات لبنانيه
اشتهرت بخصومها مع النظام السوري فخلال
ثمانينيات القرن الماضي وجهت اصابع
الاتهام الى نظام الاسد الاب في اغتيال
مفتي لبنان الشيخ حسن خالد والشيخ صبحي
الصالح الامين العام لرابطه علماء لبنان
اضافه الى النائب السني ناظم القادري اما
في عهد الاسد الابن فقد طالت القائمه
البدايه كانت مع اغتيال رئيس الوزراء رفيق
الحريري الذي قضى معه ايضا 18 شخصا بينهم
الوزير باسل فليحان لاحقا اغتيل ايضا كل
من الصحفيين سمير قصير وجبران تويني
والامين العام للحزب الشيوعي اللبناني
جورج حاوي والنائب عن حزب المستقبل وليد
عيدو والنائبين بير امين الجميل وانطوان
غانم عن حزب الكتائب اضافه الى اللواء
وسام
الحسن ونرحب بضيفي حول هذا الموضوع من
بيروت وائل ابو فاعور الوزير السابق
والقيادي في الحزب التقدمي الاشتراكي ومن
اسطنبول فايز ساره الكاتب والسياسي سوري
المعارض اهلا بكما وابدا مع السيد وائل
ابو فاعور من بيروت ماذا قرات فيما كشفه
تحقيق قناه الجزيره سيدي هل قدم لكم انتم
في الحزب التقدمي الاشتراكي اي معلومات
جديده حول عمليه اغتيال كمال
جمبلات فم الواضح ان التقرير الذي اعد كان
فيه الكثير من الاحتراف والكثير من الجهد
الذي بذل والذي القى الضوء بشكل واضح جدا
على عملي الاغتيال التي تكاد تكون من اشهر
واوضح عمليات الاغتيال في لبنان التي لا
لبس في ان وجهه الاتهام فيها هي النظام
الحاكم في دمشق لاول مره يكون ها يكون
هناك يعني هذه الاحاطه بعمليه الاغتيال
بالشكل الذي حصل في التقرير الذي عرض على
قناه الجزيره اول مره يعرض للعلن ولكن
لديكم انتم ك كحزب هل توافرت لديكم هذه
العناصر ربما لمحاكمه الجاني فيما
بعد العناصر موجوده منذ زمن والمعلومات
موجوده منذ زمن ولكن كان غياب القدره
السياسيه او غياب القدره القضائيه على
محاكمه النظام الحاكم في دمشق وعلى محاكمه
المجرمين الذين هم يعني يعرفون بالاسماء
ومنهم اشخاص لا يزالوا لا يزالون حتى
اللحظه في مواقع مسؤوليه في النظام الحاكم
في سوريا
لذلك المعلومات مهمه جدا ووفير ولكن لم
يكن في لبنان هناك اي اداه لمحاسبه القتله
او لوضع حد للجرائم النظام الحاكم في دمشق
كان يستعمل الارهاب كان يستعمل القتل
الاغتيال كاداه سياسيه مشروعه ولم يكن احد
يحاسبه على هذا الامر لذلك تجرا في
اغتيالات و على مدى السنوات والسنوات التي
وصلت الى يعني سنتين او ثلاث
سنوات القليله الماضيه وكان دائما يعتمد
هذا الا اسلوب ويعرف انه حتى مع المحكمه
الدوليه هو يستطيع ان يقوم بهذه
الاغتيالات وان ينجو من العقاب السيد فايس
ساره هل هل يبدو اتهام النظام السوري ان
كان في اغتيال كمال جنبلاط او ما تبعه من
الاغتيالات السياسيه الاخرى
منطقيا يعني انا بعتقد انه لا ماه منطقي
عمليا
اللجوء لعمليات الاغتيال هو خارج النهج
السياسي تقليدي اللي يفترض انه يعني
الانظمه والدول والحكام انهم يتابعوه
الاغتيال هو عمليه عنفيه مدانه هي عمليه
لم اتحدث عن منطقيه عمليه الاغتيال وانما
تحدثت عن منطقيه اتهام النظام السوري
باغتيال كمال جنبلاط
نعم اذا اذا هيك انا بعتقد انه ايه نعم
هناك منطقيه كبرى اي في مؤشرات كثيره
الحقيقه وما بعرف اذا كان الاستاذ ابو
فاعور اي وبعتقد انه لدى الحزب التقدمي
الاشتراكي بلبنان
اي وثائق و وشهادات مهمه كشف ال التقرير
اللي اعته الجزيره بعض جوانبها ال هذا ال
كلياته بكد انه يعني النظام هو اللي قتل
فعلا كمال جنبلاط يمكن ما في بايدنا شيء
مستمسك لكن حتى بالروايات متداوله في
سوريا و وفي بعض
الاوساط بيتهم اشخاص محددين بيقولوا انه
هذول الاشخاص فعلا هن اللي قاموا بهذ
العمليه وهذا معروف يعني معروف في بعض
الاوساط ما هو معروف على اي اساس كان
النظام السوري يحدد قوائمه في عمليه
الاغتيالات السياسيه من كان خصم النظام
السوري
سياسيا هلا بشكل اساسي في يعني بسوريا
الاغتيالات كانت تتخذ قرار الاغتيال كان
يتخذ على اعلى مستويات يعني في في في
السلطه وغالبا هو هي المستويات المتعلقه
بالرئاسه يعني حافظ الاسد هو الذي يتخذ
قرارات خطيره من هذا وه والدلالات
هي لها علاقه بالاهداف يعني مثلا اي اول
واحده من اهم العمليات الاغتيال اللي تمت
بلبنان من قبل النظام بعض صدوع صعود حافظ
الاسد لسط السلطه هو اغتيال العقيد محمد
اللواء محمد عمران وهو احد العشره اللي
كانوا باللجنه العسكريه يعني احد رفاق
حافظ الاسد في الفتره التي سبقت انقلاب 8
اذار هذا الشيء معروف وحتى يعني مشهور
كثير لكن طمس ولم يجري الحديث عنه قتل شخص
ثاني مثل صلاح الدين البيطار وهو كان رجل
يعني لم يقبل تقول بان الموضوع طمس ايضا
في قضيه كمال كمال جملات الملف اغلق
اغلقته السلطات اللبنانيه ودون توجيه
الاتهام لاحد وهنا انتقل الذا لم يكن
بعيدا عن اراده النظام وق الاستاذ وائل
ابو فاعور لماذا يتمكن فريق صحفي من
الوصول ومن الكشف عن معلومات تعرض لاول
مره اين دور الاجهزه الامنيه
اللبنانيه
اولا اسمحي لي بس فقط ان اقول بان ما تفضل
به الاستاذ فايز هو صحيح هكذا قرار اغتيال
لا يمكن ان يتخذ الا على اعلى مستويات
السلطه في سوريا يعني على مستوى القياده
او رئيس النظام في سوريا ثانيا كمال جملات
كان لدى النظام السوري كل الدوافع
المطلوبه لاجل اغتياله لانه كان في موقع
التناقض الفكري التنا التناقض الاخلاقي
والتناقض السياسي مع النظام السوري وحتى
مع حزب البعث الحاكم حتى انه قال كان يعني
يتجرا على ال المسؤولين السوريين وقال مره
لحافظ الاسد بان حزبكم هو حزب خاو من
الناحيه الفكريه والحزب لديكم ليس بالامر
الجدي وكماان جنبلاط اهم من هذا كله رفض
الدخول السوري الى لبنان تدخل النظام
السوري في لبنان وقال اني ساوا هذا التدخل
ثالثا هناك عنصر اضافي في اغتيال كمال
جملات هو علاقته بالثوره الفلسطينيه انت
تعلمين بان كان هناك محاولات دائ ئما من
قبل النظام في دمشق بوضع اليد على الثوره
الفلسطينيه بالهيمنه على الثوره
الفلسطينيه وكان جزء من الموقف من كمال
جملات هو
امتداد هل لا يزال من الممكن متابعه هذه
القضيه جنائيا و وقضائيا ومن المسؤول عن
عمليه المتابعه
تاريخيا نعم نعم من من الممكن لا اقول لك
بصراحه هذا الامر لا يعننا كثيرا لانه لدى
وليد جملات مفهوم بانه ينتظر الى جانب
النهر متى تمر جثه عدوه وعاجلا ام اجلا
ستمر جثه هذا النظام امام اعيننا لان ما
يحصل في سوريا اليوم لا يمكن ان ينتهي الا
بان ينتصر الشعب السوري اما عن سؤالك
لماذا لم تستكمل تحقيقات اي قاضي في ذلك
الوقت كان يجرؤ في لبنان على ان يوجه
الاتهام الى مسؤول سوري معروف بعينه
وباسمه كان هناك نوع من السطوه وكان هناك
نوع من الرعب على كل الاجهزه القضائيه
والامنيه اللبنانيه نحن نحن
نا اكثر العداله بمعناها بان ت هذه هذه
العمليه لم تكن الوحيده نعم الاغتيالات
التي وقعت بعد
ذلك لم تكن الوحيده وهناك الكثير من
الاغتيالات لم لمره وحيده انشئت المحكمه
الدوليه هذه المحكمه ربما تصدر حكمه في
العام 2018 ربما يشعر النظام السوري بانه
ادينا مره من المرات ولكن اليوم اعتقد
اننا اصبحنا في مكان اخر اليوم النظام في
سوريا يقتل دون حساب يقتل مئات الاف
المواطنين السوريين دون حساب وليس هناك من
يحاسبه وبالامس وفود كانت من بعض الدول
الاوروبيه تاتي لتخطب ود النظام دليل على
من مستوى السقوط الاخلاقي على المستوى
الدولي وغير الدولي في التعامل مع هذا
النظام الذي كل يوم يتف في مقتله الشعب
السوري ما جدوى اتهام النظام السوري
باغتيال كمال جمبلات و وغيره من القاده
السياسيين في في لبنان في ظل كل الجرائم
وكل ما يجري من جرائم في
سوريا يعني انا بعتقد انه يعني هذا جزء من
من حاله التوصيف لسلوك نظام داب على عمليه
القتل سواء كان القتل الفردي كما هو كما
هي حالات الاغتيال التي نفذت في اكثر من
مكان وخاصه في لبنان حيث مسرح العمليات
الاساسي للنظام طوال يعني عقدين او ثلاث
ثلاثه او عمليات الاباده والقتل الجماعي
واللي لا لا تقتصر على عهد بشار الاسد
وانما نست نستذكر الان في هذا الحديث
مجازر حماى مجازر حلب وجسر الشغور المذابح
اللي تمت بسجن
تدمر وهي تشبه تماما ما يقوم به بشار
الاسد ونظامه الان في هذه الحاله من من
عمليات القتل واضح انه هناك تواطؤ وهذا
احد الاسرار التي جعلت قضيه وليد كمال
جنبلاط ط ط طي الادراج يعني انا بعتقد انه
ليست القضيه فقط هي قضيه قضاه لا يستطيعون
او قضيه مؤسسات لا تستطيع في لبنان ان
تفتح هذا الموضوع هناك تواطؤ دولي كبير
حتى حتى يعني من من شخصيات ومنظمات نامت
على القصه
وبالتالي تحاول ان تدعم بقاء هذا النظام
شكرا لك من اسطنبول السيد فايز ساره
الكاتب والسياسي السوري المعارض الشكر
موصول ايضا لسيد وائل ابو فاعور الوزير
السابق والقيادي في الحزب التقدمي
الاشتراكي كنت معنا من بيروت بهذا
مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد شكرا لكم
والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء